une petite révolution de palais depuis
150 ans une maison parisienne fabriquer
les robes des avocates et bien elles
viennent de demander cette maison en
pierre cardin bel anniversaire pierre
cardin qui fête ses 75 ans aujourd'hui
de redessiner cette robe la maison a
demandé à carvin de faire une robe
antistress voyons la réaction des
principales intéressées avec sophie
rolland et vincent bouffartigue fini les
vieilles robe d'avocat là c'est de
vendre le même modèle depuis 150 ans on
a décidé ici de dépoussiérer la bi
traditionnelle
donc en fait la matière est différente
mais ce qui est beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus légères beaucoup plus légère mais
je vous le sentez oui oui le fait elle
est beaucoup plus souple et c'est là
qu'est la bouche bée m c'était un petit
peu moins chaud l'été
oui certainement certainement qui
surtout affreux sales des robes
entièrement redessinée par pierre cardin
qui a déjà remodelé la vie des
militaires et des infirmières
bon c'est une robe qui est très pratique
le gardien légèreté d'issue c'est ce qui
en fait 7
cette nouveauté est vu le boutonnage est
très différent nous avons fait un bout
tana qui évidemment est très laid
pression' et c'est à dire ça se
dépréciant selon lui des boutons on est
dans la technologie d'aujourd'hui
mais la vraie révolution technologique
de cette robe est ailleurs elle est anti
stress c'est une finition qui consiste à
ajouter des particules métalliques dans
le dernier bain donc de teinture et qui
permettrait de décharger l'électricité
statique du corps antistress antistress
monjauze plus maintenant
on ne peut plaider dans le stress un
prix cinq mille francs une europe qui
sera commercialisée en septembre
les hommes du barreau quant à eux
devront patienter d'ici à la fin de
l'année pour commencer leur essayages